so uh reading from the daily mail now it
says
a a mayor in ohio
has threatened the city's entire school
board with criminal charges unless they
resign over a highly sexual writing
writing prompts that teachers gave to
underage students
hudson mayor craig schubert
delivered the harsh
ultimatum during a school board meeting
on monday garnering loud applause from
outraged parents who also spoke out on
the issue
i'll tell you a little bit about these
about this writing assignment that has
been called pornographic and it is
but first let's just let's hear from
this again is uh hudson mayor craig
shubert
and let's hear him talking to the school
board listen
members of the board my name is craig
shubert i'm the mayor of this city
it has come to my attention
that your educators
are distributing essentially what is
child pornography
in the classroom
i've spoken to a judge this evening
she's already confirmed that
so i'm going to give you a simple choice
you either choose to resign from this
board of education
or you will be charged
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
that is
that almost brings a tear
to my eye
you know i think i think we've added to
the list of acceptable reasons for for
men to cry tears of joy
in response to that
i'd say
mayor craig shubert i don't know
anything else about him
i don't know where he stands on any
other issue but i would vote for him for
president tomorrow if it were up to me
i'd i didn't make him president of the
united states tomorrow if i could
without knowing anything else about him
because just that alone tells me that he
that puts him
uh above
almost every other republican
at every level of government everywhere
in the country
that he is willing to do that
that he's taking this issue that
seriously
and is going to use all of the power at
his disposal
to protect kids and to put an end to
this degeneracy and filth in the school
system
let's go back to the daily mail to see
what assignment he's talking about
it says at issue are the highly
inappropriate writing prompts
distributed to students in the liberal
arts writing class at hudson high school
including here are the writing prompts
given to kids by adults
write a sex scene you wouldn't show your
mom
describe your favorite part of a man's
body using only verbs
and write an x-rated disney scenario
uh that those were some of the writing
prompts
it was
continuing the article says it was
unclear whether the inappropriate
written material given to school
children truly violates child
pornography laws as the mayor claimed
but nevertheless parents in the district
were outraged i think it certainly does
ohio law does prohibit sending harmful
or obscene material to or sharing it
with a minor
though this statute usually refers to
sexting or sending obscene images
the relevant statute exempts obscene
material that is presented for bona fide
educational purposes leaving the legal
questions around the controversy murky
uh
yeah well they they can sort that out
but he talked to a judge
and this is the right way to handle it
this is exactly how we have to handle we
have to start talking about it
in this way
you know for me it's very simple because
we've
we've kind of we've granted this
exemption
to teachers and people in the in the
public school system
for no good reason
you know we've kind of waved the wand
and say and we've said well they're
exempt
from all of the normal rules of decency
that we apply to everybody else
so if um
if there was a grown adult
who you know your
14 year old daughter
met online
and you've got to look at the the
messages going back and forth between
this grown adult and the 14 year old
daughter
and uh the adult said to your daughter
uh you know was was trying to prompt
your daughter
to write x-rated things
i mean what if he had said uh describe
your favorite your favorite part of a
man's body using only verbs
i mean what if this was some some creepy
pervert online an adult talking to your
14 year old daughter
that exact prompt
giving her quote unquote writing prompts
that he could read and enjoy
there would be no question that it's
illegal
that this is the sexual harassment and
abuse of a child
he's not gonna be able to hide behind
any well it's for for educational
purposes i was worried about her you
know creative writing i was trying to
help her build her creative writing
skills
he wouldn't be able to hide behind that
and yet if it if it happens in a
classroom
it's okay
why
you know no if anything
it's worse in a classroom
they can't really get worse but if it's
the fact that it's in a classroom if
that affects the severity of the crime
at all it's only to make it worse
because these are adults that you have
entrusted your children with
and their job is to educate your
children
and when they use that trust and that
role
to sexually indoctrinate
abuse and harass kids it makes it even
worse
so this is exactly what should happen
not just for this but
distributing
sex ed
material
with unnecessarily graphic pictures and
depictions and descriptions
we all know the story i've talked about
many of them on the show over the years
you know sex ed for middle schoolers it
talks about
masturbation and sodomy and anal sex and
all kinds of things that's that's
happening in schools all across the
country
and this is the point that i've always
made about it
that these conversations if you were to
take them out of the classroom and put
them on the playground between the adult
and the child or put them and put them
online or anywhere else
we would all of us unquestioningly agree
that this is sexual abuse and that
person's a pervert and a pedophile and
should be locked in prison
so the only thing that i would add to
them what the mayor said here is uh is
yeah certainly
[Music]
the the board of education should resign
or be arrested
and all of the teachers who distributed
this and who are involved in this every
single one of them should be should be
in prison
they shouldn't be able to hide behind
what was the curriculum i had no choice
the curriculum called for me to
solicit x-rated material from 14 year
olds
mayor craig shubert 2024
i've decided he's my uh
ron just said i still like desantis but
for me right now schubert is uh
just has just gone to the lead if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up and share it with all your
friends